I'm calm okay peace be with you welcome
to the Dene show subscribe if you
haven't already Conor McGregor this
episode is a special one for you with a
special message we're going to be
talking about the mistake that you made
probably the biggest mistake that you
made in your life and with hope at the
end how you can go ahead and take this
mistake and change it learn from it
benefit from it so you can gain success
by heating this wonderful advice and I
got an Irish man on the show to help me
deliver it to you so don't go anywhere
we'll be right back this is the this is
the venue this is the danger
this is the theme you know this is the
thing please be with us Li lei : a
connoisseur I'm Tula Abdul Malik Ryan
now of Irish descent
yes how you been doula very good very
well good to see well yeah just a man
for the job we got a special message for
our Irish but we love the Irish bro our
Irish brothers in humanity and Allah
Conor McGregor you heard of him I have
heard of him he's Irish he is I from
Dublin I think right yes we got a
special message we want to do a special
episode for him I'm gonna go to this
clip and get your take on it okay me and
me and Jesus I killed I'm killed with
all the gods gods recognize gods all
right so what are your thoughts on when
you hear something like this yeah I mean
obviously you see you see that you hear
the people laughing at what he says and
you see a lot of it what he does is like
an act and people find it very
entertaining and this is how he got
popular this is how he you know is the
biggest highest-paid fighter in that and
stuff like that so and actually I was
reading a book and it's interesting and
many of us as Muslims we know this that
a lot of these fighters whatever
whatever they're in all of these sports
figures to be honest for the last 40
years all they've been doing is
imitating Muhammad Ali trying to be like
Muhammad Ali because Muhammad Ali was
someone who came along at a time when
boxing was a little struggling a little
bit and he but he was able to with his
personality and by saying things that
were got people's attention and seemed
crazy and by making big boasts and then
backing it up he got like people really
loved that so a lot of people so he's
trying to do that act of kind of
imitating but you see that he kind of I
especially for us as Muslims anyone who
understands the reality of the
seriousness of these things he goes far
overboard here you know and he says
things that he thinks are funny but that
really show that he doesn't understand
what he's talking about so you see first
he's saying that him and him and Jesus
are cool versus
I tell you what it's not a man alive
that can be me but Jesus ain't alive is
he so I don't know maybe he could come
back from the dead nah I don't know
and I'd still group us you know it's
like he's he's you know and this is this
is something that but at the same to the
same time he sees Jesus as a human being
that he can kind of be cool with and
interact but at same time then he goes
say that Jesus is like a God and he's
also a God so you see the danger of not
recognizing the separation between
humans and God and understanding that
and and that understand we are not gods
and we are not we shouldn't put
ourselves in that level and that was
something Muhammad Ali for the most part
he Chi he was careful about for the most
part he would say that he's mother
he's Ummah you know I'm beautiful I'm
pretty I'm great I'm the greatest of the
people but he would normally not compare
himself to God but even he realized that
he kind of maybe win overboard at times
in the way he would boast and talk about
himself and that that when you do that
sometimes God humbles you too because
and not because God doesn't like you and
it's not even but actually if God
humbles you in this life when you're
saying something like that is actually a
sign that God wants something good for
you that's that you can couldn't let you
keep going and going and not humble you
but now is it time to reflect that's
exactly what we want we want to take
this situation and derive some good for
it from it and just like at a time you
know this is amazing we had the famous
George st. Pierre who's a UFC fighter we
did a show specifically also for him I
can't I can't sleep at night now I'm
going crazy at his shoes man I and I
need to relax I need to get out for a
while you know I'm I don't know what I'm
gonna do any I am I'm I feel like I'm
gonna let everything out now but I have
to keep some of my stuff some of part of
my life personal okay now his boxing
trainer is also Muslim so we know so he
actually contacted us and he he said
that he sent that show to him so it got
to another UFC champ now we got another
UFC champ that we want to get the
message to so we're going to leave all
of your guys help to help this to go out
now we want to derive some good from it
so we talked about you know one quality
of
of you can't go wrong with is
controlling that ego and being humble
you know to mean this is something that
all the messengers of God taught knowing
your limits and you mentioned Mohammed
Ali you know we know I want aspect it's
show business right and many people
don't understand that even as human
beings you know you'll say one word
you'll destroy a marriage you'll say the
wrong paragraph wrong side you end up in
life in jail in prison but now the words
we say against the Almighty I'm killed
with all the gods gods recognize gods I
was gonna get it regardless sooner or
later it's coming with or without you
and then the God came and blessed you
with it ya know about that coffee thing
any man god man I mean not only that I
whipped God as well had the one who's
created us giving us all these blessings
that you couldn't even throw a punch
a jab blocker punch without these
blessings from God to insult God like
this are we thinking what do you think
ya know this is in it like we said
that's why it's good that God humbles us
sometimes and we all have that this in
our life even if we're not you know
champions and we're not in show business
we all have times where we come if
things are going well we become very
sure of ourselves we think oh I have
this job I have this car I have this
money because of me because I work hard
and sometimes God has to Humble us a
little bit and many of us have this
experience through sicknesses through
illness through some losing someone
close to us we suddenly realize like we
have nothing like everything we have God
just gave it to us out of his you know
mercy and his compassion towards us and
we should just be grateful for it the
main thing is to be grateful for what we
have and always be humbled like as you
said to realize that everything we have
is from is from God it's not from
ourselves
how is the situation with the Irish
people are have they been I mean we have
one example like Liam Neeson you know
him yeah he was in Turkey at one time he
couldn't stand it down but after some
time he was just like there was word of
him actually accepting Islam he's Irish
also right he is Irish he is Irish yeah
and you know and I think that he said
that you know he began to appreciate the
the beauty of the of the ax then and the
culture and you find out with many
people at the Irish one good thing we
really say is Irish is that Irish are
people of course even though we're in
Europe which is true of some other
people here we were at we were not one
of the people colonizing
but we were colonized by the English so
I wish were people on the bottom of the
rain in Europe and people have a long
history of being oppressed and of
identifying with other oppressed groups
so you find so many people Irish people
identifying with Palestinians
identifying with their struggle
identifying with struggles all over the
world identifying with different
cultures so you have many Irish people
who are close to Muslims and who know
Muslims but now you know but but not
they're not necessarily a religious
connection but they're connecting on
cultural and other ways so we want to
know that again it's important to this
Islam is a message for everyone and we
want to you know share the message in
the best way possible we have to be the
best example and sure I like that we're
going to take a break but that's right
Muslims right now it's sad to say I'd
probably most oppressed people on the
earth Irish have gone through it we got
another connection we got more
connections that talk about don't go
anywhere Connor we'll be right back
leaders not a god all right if I told
you who don't believe in God if I told
you to this glass sprang into existence
this glass made itself no man made this
glass if you believe it what you believe
I just told you this thing made itself
well I tell you you Andrea right now
some somebody's doubting it yeah so I'm
giving you the answer that's you and
believe if I turn it is television
station just popped into existence it
just no man made it
you said Muhammad Ali's crazy all right
well this glass can't make itself if I
told you those clothes you have on wove
themselves
nobody created them those clothes made
themselves you and believe it but if
you're if your clothes didn't make
itself if that glass couldn't make
yourself if this building didn't make
itself then how did the moon get out
there how do the stars and Jupiter
Neptune and Mars from the Sun how to
nature how all this come here didn't
know why is something planning to Megan
so what I'm saying is I believe that we
want to be judged should a man like
Hitler kill all the Jews and get away
with it
somebody should punish him maybe get it
don't get it now he get it when you die
it help eternity so what I'm gonna do
when I get out of boxes is to get myself
ready to meet God because my plane might
blow up
don't planes blow up in this country
sometimes in crash don't people die
every day subscribe right now
back here on the Dean show with my Irish
brother here we did a show it was back
it was SD actually stand there dad and I
were HD I was called Irish and lovin
Islam you actually come from a
background of being a Christian and you
tell us in summary what what had you so
interested I you I know you read a
Autobiography of Malcolm X and yeah and
and many other things but in summary
what was it about Islam that captivated
you captive so as you said I grew up you
know grew up in a Catholic family as
most Irish people are Catholic and
actually it's very intertwined with the
culture and but you know as most people
buy time I was in high school in college
I wasn't really into religion you know I
was into other things at that time but I
got fascinated with african-american
history with Malcolm X so I became
really into the into Malcolm X and
studying from a historical perspective
but you know Malcolm X one thing that he
stressed and Malcolm X spent most of his
life even though he was a powerful
political figure he actually spent most
of his time trying to teach people about
Islam and recruiting people to Islam
first in the Nation of Islam but then
when he realized the Nation of Islam was
not the total truth when he accepted a
Sunni Islam he spent his time trying to
teach people about Sunni Islam and
trying to attract people to them and he
especially said for white people in
America that they should study Islam
that because of his powerful experience
on oddware he writes that amazing letter
he felt that this is something Islam if
it's actually taken in and actually
appreciated and practiced is actually
something that can destroy racism and
something that can bring people true
Brotherhood and that is actually what I
did find myself when I became Muslim I
when I was to first spending time around
Muslims in the college setting and
that's why I love the college setting
and so I came back to be a chaplain you
have Muslims from all over the world you
know we maybe had 10 different 10 15
different Muslims at a gathering for
iftar each one coming from a different
country in the world but all bound
together by by Islam by by the their
love of allah subhana wa ta'ala by their
love of the prophets peace be upon him
and just being so humble and i remember
sharing an iftar and we're all sitting
on the floor and just you know after
that period of fasting you're finally
getting some food and you feel so calm
and you feel the brotherhood and
sisterhood and that was
actually what made me feel just in my
heart that this is the truth that this
is what Allah wants for us similar to
the experience that Malcolm had when he
was on it's pretty clear when you look
in Islam the purpose of life why we're
being created it's not just blind faith
there's evidence proof it's overwhelming
when you look at it there's no other way
that you're going to look left or right
but you got to look straight and say
this is indeed you know like you know
there's no other explanation for it then
and then being a way of life from the
Creator it's it's amazing and that's why
I said like I said like it you know now
I work at a Catholic University I have
probably even more understanding for for
Catholicism than I did in the past but
and you see why naturally human beings
and you find many of the principles
being taught that are the same
principles and you see why humans are
attracted to it but the basic thing
about Islam that I think will always win
anyone who seriously looks at just the
LA ilaha illa Allah there is no god but
God there's nothing worthy of worship
except God so everything else in this
world is creation it's something
different than God God's creation don't
worship the creation worship the Creator
that makes sense to anyone who thinks
about it and I think that's where people
end up they turn away from religion they
go away from what their parents were
upon because now making God into a man
and now you can envision throwing a jab
at him or a cross I'll knock him out
versus Jesus in the earth no I tell ya
well it's not a man alive that can be me
but Jesus ain't alive is he so I don't
know maybe you could come back from the
dead nah I don't know
I'd still will bust you can't do that
with God because God's not a man in
order he died on no cross I mean and
that that concept just makes sense what
you're saying worship the Creator not
the creation and from there your heart
just Tunes in it recognizes the Fatah
let me go to the next clip because
there's a lot of people that are upset
one Christian pastor in particular let's
see what he had to say I'm telling you
what I'm gonna pray that God strikes
this guy dead do you know why he's name
is Conor McGregor yes and he's the UFC I
mean these somebody guys these guys are
table strike him dead I mean uh whatever
the hardcore and I think that guy's
probably trying to get some attention
but but but we know that anger comes on
and we know in the Muslim community
sometimes our anger comes out when
people say things that we know are out
of line out of pocket but as we start it
off by saying the point really is not
for us as human beings to become angry
with people especially if they haven't
even been given the message but to go
and just talk to them and try to give
them the message and like you said make
something positive come out of it like a
loss Allah you see the way that Allah if
Allah wanted to strike him dead when he
said that Allah what could have struck
him dead when he finished boom it would
be over Allah doesn't want to do that
Allah is giving him more time because
Allah wants to teach him somebody give
him a chance to change and so we hope he
takes that opportunity definitely and
made people want to make Muslims not
like you know where the where the
vigilantes and violent but we got a
message of love and hope and we want him
now God Almighty a lot of times my next
question we put in all of this work in
this effort we pound our chest and we
say I I did is my training I you know
without that but what about the other
element because again we couldn't if we
didn't have this air to breathe the eyes
to see with if we didn't have the nerves
inside of our bodies you know just a
disk goes out l4 ll back the back eight
nine disk you're out you're done you
can't do anything Subhan Allah and like
I said before that's the one thing that
you realize especially if you're sick or
something and you need help you can't
even get up and go to the bathroom for
yourself you can't do anything for
yourself you really realize how weak you
are and like I said and Allah mentions
this in the Quran that the human being
when they get wealth when they get
status they tend to become arrogant
and sometimes Allah has to Humble us to
remind us of what's really going on and
inshallah the best of us are people who
have that humility even if we're given
blessings and then alive we're grateful
when we're given blessings instead of
becoming arrogant if we're just grateful
for it and try to use it for good then
Allah will keep giving us more and more
blessing so how could he now he's tuning
in the message gets to him how can he
take this situation he hears this now
because every heart he's you know you
mentioned the African Americans he loves
the you know the bling-bling the hip-hop
you know he can go back and connect with
the roots of Kunta Kinte and Malcolm X
Muhammad Ali they all found purpose in
submission to the will of God Islam they
found purpose then they found
contentment but will you ever doesn't
matter how many Rolls Royces you have
how many Lambos how many selfies and
muscles you grow is that where the
purpose is and contentment and Happiness
yeah no it isn't and I think you can
talk to people who have those things and
a lot of times they put on the front
just like who put on the front for the
purpose of show business a lot of times
people put on the front and a fake
picture that this is bringing them
happiness is bringing contentment but
deep in their heart they know when
they're alone when they're reflecting
when they've gotten a little humbled
that this is not bringing them happiness
and but we want to know that happiness
is out there and don't don't keep
chasing it through material things don't
even keep chasing it to fame and
whatever you got Fame because you have
certain skills you have certain
blessings people like your personality
that's okay but now use that to show
people that you you can still learn and
grow this is what we love about Malcolm
X Muhammad Ali any people that we look
up to they may have gained their fame
through different reasons but what I
think makes them people that we still
talk about now and people that people
still love and look up to rather than at
people that were forgotten is that they
were humble enough to learn lessons to
improve to grow into change so we always
want to be able to change and I think
that's that's what we would love to see
from Conor McGregor with you're very
well known make a change come to some
day I mean it will be beautiful you know
there's other other famous Irish Muslims
like Everlast the rapper from House of
Pain and stuff I really feel like he
could be started P could be part of sort
of movement is to show that being Irish
and being Muslim makes
together and that's about worshiping the
Creator not the creation something I
guarantee effete sincere and he looks
into it he would indeed see that it
provides all the evidence rational
logical and there's no other way but to
see that this is the truth look another
misconception that is clear right now
just by us sitting together
look bosnian American Irish we talked
about African American Muhammad Ali and
it's for the whole of mankind because
it's a universal message we'll be right
back with more in today's show don't go
anywhere
when I get out of box and I want to I'm
going to do all I can to help people
that's why I remember Johnnie Walker
because a poor man came all the way to
America there's a bunch of boys need
some money and somebody's calling me to
help him God is watching me God is God
don't praise me because I be Joe Frazier
God don't give him none by Joe Frazier
God don't cut them about Ingle america
as far as real wealth is all he is he
wants to know how do we treat each other
how do we help each other so I'm gonna
dedicate my life to using my name in
popularity helping charges helping
people uniting people brain people
bombing each other because of religious
beliefs we need somebody in the world to
help make peace so when I die if there's
a heaven I want to see it because we
live how old 80 years the odds are if
fat in this room some of you can be dead
20 years from now some of you will be
dead 50 years now some of them be dead
thirty and some will be there 60 70
years we all want to die soon subscribe
right now
here on the Dean show you know certain
stereotypes are attached to certain
people and I know I mean I'm just
sitting with a perfect example of an
Irish Muslim that he's got to go beyond
the beer and you know the foul language
there's got there's more to life and
people in this position now the young
kids will look at someone like that a
celebrity status and start to think
imagine everybody starts thinking that
they're gods gods recognize gods you
know what I mean now now we've gotten
more towards you know up paganism and
setting the worst of examples because
now we're just lost the soul is just
bankrupt you might have all the money
but your soul and heart is dead but
there's more there's got to be the Irish
people will connect with this message
because it's in all of us definitely and
I think you know I think we all find a
lot of people especially for Irish
people who are in America now most of
them have been here for a while their
families have been here for many
generations they kind of hummed aloud
there's a strong sense where people
still hold on to being Irish because
that means something to them but
unfortunately too many of them it means
something silly as we'll see
and March 17th comes around it means to
them getting drunk you know it's
partying all day like this is somehow
showing pride in being Irish this has
nothing to do with what being Irish is
really all about what is Irish being all
about I mean being Irish like I said is
all about really for the people come
there is really about siding with the
oppressed it's really about faith family
you know it's really about identifying
with the people who who are downtrodden
and really standing up for what's right
as well as having you know an ancient
culture and ancient traditions that that
we try to you know uphold and try to
follow but those traditions are based on
values that we find in Islam they're not
based on values of partying and and
material consumers culture like we were
talking about and so that's a really sad
and this is why one thing about Islam is
that the Prophet peace be upon him he
taught us to know your lineage to study
your history to know where your people
came from why not because to be overly
proud of it or nationalistic or in terms
of separating from other people but we
like we said the Muslims are all United
together and we want
unite humanity together under Islam but
when you know where you came from when
you know your values it helps you to
know other people better it helps you to
know what's important as you know a god
says in the Quran that we made you in
two different nations and tribes so that
you might know one another so the fact
that we're in different nations and
tribes is not an accident it's not a
mistake
God did it on purpose and there's value
in knowing that but once you know what
that really is about what's really true
nature of your heritage is about it
helps you to realize what's important in
life and what's important in life is
your connection with the Creator and
trying to uphold values and help
humanity let's go and because it's about
shifting loyalty many people started to
you know large numbers of fans coming in
they feel like okay now this is our man
who represents us and you're only as
strong is who you put all your effort in
and you see that at the end what goes up
comes down your human being you're weak
and hopefully this can be a learning
lesson for Conor McGregor to turn that
loyalty to the creator of the heavens
and earth Allah now tell us what's in
the last few minutes that we have let's
talk about some very important concepts
you talked about this when we were an SD
and we had some great feedback talking
about the deep love that we have for
Jesus peace be upon him you know but
Jesus also never called people to
worship Him and people understanding
also the concept of original goodness
not original sin can you get up into
these core simple beliefs that just
resonate and I can I guarantee if a
person is here they'll say I agree with
that and if you agree with that then you
should accept that mashallah I'm glad
I'm glad you mentioned that because I
think that is really important for
people who do have an attachment to the
faith you know Jesus is a very important
figure and and for all Catholics and all
Christians but you know in an Irish I
think they feel a special identification
with Jesus and with Mary especially and
these are figures that are in the Quran
the figures that are very important in
our faith but it's important not to take
them in the wrong way their beautiful
role models and beautiful examples of
human beings who are submitted to God in
the most perfect way not not of people
who and we don't when we elevate them to
being God that's that's making a mistake
and that's really going astray and
you'll find a lot of people that's where
a lot of people do get confused because
they don't know what that means
I mean I think they think they want they
want to have that identification to know
that God cares for them but the way to
do it is not by turning God into a human
being the way to do it is by realizing
that God cares for you as a human being
that God is there to answer your prayers
directly that you don't need to go
through any intermediary that you don't
need to go through a priest or a prophet
or anybody that the prophets give bring
messages but you go you go speak to God
directly you pray to God directly you're
going to stand before God alone on the
day of judgment and so you want to have
that relationship with God so Christians
who are listening to this people who are
interested should really read about what
the Quran says in the chapter of Mary
about Mary about Jesus the example we
have of Jesus's life again was similar
to what we say we pride the Irish being
about about standing for the oppressed
being submitted to God bringing bringing
social change and really identifying
with the downtrodden in society and
that's what as we have people whose
faith have to do what advice it's very
hard it's very tempting when the whole
world opens up to you now person like
her Girma Conner who is that that you
know point where he's almost got
everything but definitely right now you
can like Ronda Rousey know if you heard
her most popular woman in the world you
know thought she was unstoppable
and then she suffered a defeat and then
shortly after she's on an interview
talking about thinking contemplating
suicide right but you got everything you
got the status you could still make it
you found so how what should someone you
know now it's like that humbling point
and you know maybe you're more receptive
to the message so what advice do you
have for someone like Conor McGregor
who's out there maybe you know he's
tuning in yeah I I hope he is I hope
this message reaches him just turn uh
really you know like we said this is an
opportunity to understand what's really
important I'm sure on some level you
know what's really important you know
who are the people and the things that
were important in your life before you
became famous the people who didn't just
jump on the bandwagon the people who
stick by you even if you lose those
those things that are important and God
is of those things God is always there
waiting for you regardless of what we
say about him
you know we as Muslims say that God like
the the greatest sin we can commit is
shirk he is comparing God to a human
being
comparing God to his creation worshiping
something else along with God but even
with even when we do that we God is
waiting for us to turn back to admit our
mistake and God will definitely accept
as we say that if we take one step
towards God God will take two steps
towards us if we go to God walking God
will come to us running and that's a
very powerful statement because we know
God is not a human being God is not a
person but it's a very powerful
statement that the only barrier between
us and God is ourselves in our decisions
so really realize what's important
realize where you're going to find
tranquility and happiness is with the
Creator and with making a life that's
really more meaningful than maybe what
you said what you thought before and I
think if you do that you have a
potential not just for yourself most
importantly but you have a potential to
influence a lot of people who are paying
attention who want to see what you're
going to do next that's it because these
are planting grounds right now that we
plant them because all this all those
rolls-royce's I got to stay behind right
and we're going to die now it's time to
do good deeds so they can flourish and
we can have the everlasting reward in
the next life God willing thank you so
much thank you all I could to some peace
be with you sometime like buddy comes
that out there you have it mr. Conor
McGregor I hope that you really
contemplate and think about the message
the wonderful advice now just as
managing I'll end with this story
imagine if someone had given you a
shovel a light a road map water and
everything you needed to go ahead and
dig up a treasure you can find any of
these tools anywhere else in the world
but the person who gave it to you that
was the only one who had these essential
items that you couldn't see in the dark
without the light you couldn't dig up
that treasure without the shovel you
couldn't survive out there without that
water in that food and then you ended up
finding the treasure because you had the
treasure map the blueprint on how to
find it and then you finally dug it up
and you forgot to give thanks to the one
who gave you the shovel the one who gave
you the light the one who gave you the
food and the water and the drain
and the roadmap how would that be you
think your trainer who helped train you
you think your wife who helped you
during those down Tron times but now the
one who gave you the abilities and the
one who actually put that treasure there
who doesn't need any of it but just put
it there to test you that when you
achieve the success will you recognize
the one who gave you the ability to be
successful and now what will you do with
all of that
will you Bhosle praise yourself and make
yourself into a deity into a god and
then be humbled and now what will you do
with that warning that sign because it's
come to you or will you go ahead and
take the advice heed the call the
message and contemplate and think think
because deaf can approach at any time
and money and fame and prestige and all
of these things that we think that feed
our egos at the end all of this stuff we
leave behind in the grave really
contemplate the day that when you had
nothing and now you have something what
are you going to do to give back to
humanity to give back to society take
what you need but now to go ahead and
recognize the one who gave you these
abilities that you couldn't even throw a
punch a jab block one stand up tall if
it wasn't for the one who gave you the
ability who gave you everything that you
have to achieve this great success I
hope that Conor McGregor you'll go ahead
and think and reflect and ponder and at
the end of the day it takes but the
sincerity and earnestness inside the
drive to just ask as the one thank the
one who made you who created you who
gave you all these faculties and
blessings to guide you and to start to
live a thankful grateful life and now
you in the position that you're in you
can make a huge impact of goodness and
plaque seeds of goodness now so when you
leave this life
you can leave a legacy of good because
many have come and gone and they've been
forgotten but how will you be remembered
is how you live this life and if you
live the good life a good life according
to the way that the Creator wants you to
live you will have lived a successful
life and then you'll have not only
success peace and tranquillity and
contentment in this life that money
cannot buy
but then definitely you will have
paradise in the next and this is the
message of all the messages including
Jesus peace be upon him Muhammad Moses
Abraham because they all call to the
same call to worship the Creator not the
creation and that's that simple message
we hope that you got to benefit from
this our brother Irish brother Conor
McGregor and we'll see you next time
tune in every week to the Dean show
visit us when you're in Chicago at our
gym we'll see you then until next time
peace be with you
Salaam alaikum so what am I gonna do it
on through fighting all there 16 years
be productive
get myself ready to meet God and go to
the best place what that makes sense
thank you
subscribe right now